Comencemos hablando de Karim Benzema
gana su primer balón de oro con 34 años
el segundo galardonado más veterano en
la historia podemos decir que es un
reconocimiento tardío pero merecido
Hola Juan un gusto un placer Un saludo
para toda latinoamérica sí es
merecidísimo el premio otorgado a Karim
Benzema figuras fundamentales del Real
Madrid para mí el mejor equipo del mundo
en este momento
y yo es clave en la obtención de la
última Champions League realmente tarde
pero justo el reconocimiento a Un
delantero fantástico que no estuvo en el
último mundial donde su selección salió
campeona del mundo va a estar ahora en
Qatar donde va a poder demostrar toda su
valía
hablando Todavía de la rama masculina Se
confirma Ya esa transición de que
estamos fuera de la época de Cristiano
Ronaldo y Lionel Messi
Bueno ahí tengo que de disentir con vos
podemos decirle que estamos presenciando
El ocaso de Cristiano Ronaldo pero a mí
me resulta realmente
extrañísimo e inverosímil que Lionel
Messi no haya estado preseleccionado
dentro de los 30 mejores futbolistas del
mundo
hay que entender de que este Premio Lo
otorga la revista Fran fútbol y el
premio the best lo lo este organiza y lo
da la FIFA así hay una pequeña disputa
a mí me tocó votar antes de la pandemia
cuando aún la argentino estaba
siendo figura y capitán del Barcelona y
yo dije en ese momento que mientras Leo
siguiera jugando para mí va a ser el
mejor jugador del mundo y lo sigo
repitiendo Por más que no le den los
premios para mí es el mejor futbolista
del Siglo 21 Julio pasando la rama
femenina es una sorpresa que haya ganado
Elisa putellas teniendo en cuenta que
competía con las inglesas de Smith y
Lucy Brons que fueron campeones de la
Eurocopa femenina
sí es una sorpresa pero más que nada
porque está lesionada este se está
recuperando la grave lesión en la
rodilla de ligamentos cruzados y no
estaban actividad realmente es una
delantera excepcional es la segunda vez
que lo gana
el premio se instituyó hace poco para la
rama femenina y este Alexia tiene
méritos obrados para
ser considerada pero es una sorpresa que
le hayan dado el premio a una futbolista
que se está recuperando desde hace meses
de una grave lesión